a medida que el golpe militar en mi
armar entré en su segundo mes aumenta la
represión y el uso indiscriminado de la
fuerza por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad birmanas contra el movimiento
de desobediencia civil la violencia que
recuerda las atrocidades cometidas por
el tan mató nombre oficial de las
fuerzas armadas contra las minorías
étnicas en el país las protestas
reflejan un odio generalizado hacia el
pasado gobierno militar cuya dictadura
perduró durante más de 40 años informar
a las personas de su derecho a la
autodefensa de acuerdo con la ley como
población civil en el caso de violencia
ni en mar atraviesa el momento más
oscuro el rechazo la junta militar
liderada por minni aun lawn une a los
distintos grupos de la sociedad pero
quien gobierna la oposición civil cuando
la líder del gobierno depuesto anza el
sushi y parte de su cúpula están
detenidos tras el golpe militar un grupo
de 15 legisladores del partido de suu
kyi la liga nacional para la democracia
organizaron en la clandestinidad del
comité que representa la asamblea de la
unión dirigido por el líder interino del
adn de manwin cantan el sábado cuando se
vivió otra jornada sangrienta pidió a
los manifestantes que no se rindieran y
declaró a la junta como organización de
error
con el fin de formar una democracia
federal que todos los hermanos étnicos
que han estado sufriendo diversos tipos
de opresión de la dictadura durante
décadas esta revolución es la
oportunidad de que podemos unir nuestros
esfuerzos
al formar una resistencia a la unidad
desempeña un papel vital a pesar de
nuestras diferencias en el pasado este
es el momento en el que debemos unir
nuestras manos para acabar con la
dictadura de forma definitiva el taimado
se ha presentado durante décadas como la
única institución capaz de preservar la
unión en mi armar manwin kaim tan
pertenece a la minoría étnica karen que
durante años permaneció en guerra contra
el ejército birmano por lo que conoce la
importancia de mantener una alianza
civil para que la rebelión prospere